article 3 153 du code pénal de tanguy
viel un titre peu accrocheur pour un
ouvrage coup de coeur de cette librairie
ini monteyne on suit les confidences
faites à un juge d'un ouvrier brestois
coupable de meurtre c'est vraiment un
livre vraiment très émouvant sur la
relation que peut avoir un père avec son
fils là qu'il essaye d'amener malgré lui
enfin qui va emmener malgré lui dans sa
chute et la relation qu'il ya aussi avec
la société quelle quelle vision à la
société sur les ouvriers brestois de
l'époque des années 90 alors c'est plus
dédié vraiment à tout type de lecteur
pas vraiment c'est c'est très simple en
fait c'est plus de l'oralité en fait le
dialogue
en fait entre le juge et le s est
ouvrier là est transcrit sans mise en
forme
c'est vraiment un discours en discours
brut pour les amateurs de polars seuls
les bêtes de col agnel un roman choral
loin de l' enquête policière habituels
autour d'un meurtre il ya cinq racing en
fait qu'ils vont vivre la scène de
l'assassinât de cette femme qui est qui
est retrouvée morte dans une voiture
dans un sentier de randonnée pardon est
en fait les cinq personnages vont
décrire le contexte ce qu'ils ont vécu
durant le moment et ce qui s'est passé
après
au rayon bande dessinée flotte un parfum
de nostalgie un certain journaliste
belge à la houppette blonde voit ses
premières aventures mise en couleur donc
là les traits sont épurées forcer le
toutou premier c'est les prémices de
tintin alors là et rejet n'avait que 22
ans
donc c'était vraiment son tout début et
il s'imaginait pas que ce son petit
reporter n'allait durer quelques siècles
derrière lui c'est une belle découverte
je pense que pour rentrer dans un temps
aussi on peut commencer par le début ça
peut être bien depuis 1939 première date
de parution de tintin chez les soviets
près de 240 millions d'albums des 24
aventures du journaliste se sont vendus
à travers le monde